-You know, we don´t
always have enough time
to cover all of the recent news,
so here with a recap is one
of our writers, Amber Ruffin,
in a segment we call
"Amber Says What."
♫♫
-You guys,
things have been crazy!
First of all, Hurricane Harvey
caused so much devastation
that I was like, "What?!"
Then Americans banded together
and raised millions
to help the victims,
and I was like, "What! What!"
Then they were like, "Oops.
Here come 18 more storms."
And I was like, "What?"
And after Harvey, Trump didn´t
visit Houston right away,
and everyone was like,
"Wh-a-a-at?"
Then he did, and his wife
wore five-inch heels,
and I was like, "What...
kind of flood are you going to?"
Then she wore a FLOTUS hat,
and I was like, "What?!"
Then I found out
that hat is for sale.
And I was like, "Who...
else needs a FLOTUS hat?
You are literally
the only FLOTUS on Earth!"
That would be like if the
NBC store sold a hat that said,
"The black lady who works
for ´Late Night
with Seth Meyers.´"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Would you buy it?
Oh, you would? Okay.
Then Nintendo announced
that Super Mario
is officially no longer
a plumber, and I was like...
[ To tune of "Overworld Theme" ]
♫ What, what, what,
what-what-what-what? ♫
But, no, then I got worried
for him and was like...
[ Tune of "Underworld Theme" ]
♫ What-what-what-what-what? ♫
No, but, seriously,
R.I.P., Plumber Mario.
[ To the tune of "Game Over" ]
♫ What, what, what,
what-what, wh-a-a-at ♫
Then, uh...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah!
[ Tune of "Underworld Theme" ]
♫ What-what-what-what-what? ♫
Then I saw that in Utah,
that cop dragged that nurse out
of that hospital for no reason!
And I was like, "What...do you
think she is -- a black person?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
That´s not what we meant when
we were talking about equality.
Also, you know there are
no black people in your state
when even the nurses are white.
[ Audience groans ]
You don´t want to buy
the hat anymore?
That´s fine.
It wasn´t for sale anyway.
Then I read
astronaut Peggy Whitson
just got back to Earth
after 665 days
of being off the planet.
She must have gotten to Earth,
looked around, and been like,
"What...the [bleep]?!"
This has been "Amber Says What."
♫♫
-Amber Ruffin, everybody.